القرار لا يدعو الى وقف لاطلاق النار كما
تطالب الاغلبيه في المجتمع الدولي وفي
الامم
المتحده لكن القرار وهو الثاني الذي
يعتمده المجلس بشان الحرب في غزه يؤكد على
ضروره حمايه المدنيين والاعيان المدنيه
والمرافق الانسانيه وايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه وفقا للقانون الدولي ويطالب
بتعيين منسق للشؤون الانسانيه وانشاء اليه
لتسريع ايصال المساعده الانسانيه دون
عوائق لقد كان هذا امرا صعبا لكنه تحقق
منذ بدايه هذا الصراع بذلت الولايات
المتحده جهودا بلا كلال لتخفيف هذه الازمه
الانسانيه لايصال المساعدات المنقذه
للحياه الى غزه واخراج الرهاءن وايضا
للضغط من اجل حمايه المدنيين الابرياء
والعاملين في المجال الانساني والعمل من
اجل سلام دائم ان تصويت اليوم يعزز تلك
الجهود ويوفر الدعم المباشر
لدبلوماسيين القرار افرغ من مطالب مهمه
وعلى راسها الدعوه لوقف الاعمال القتاليه
وهو لذلك لن يكون فاعلا على الارض بحسب
تحذير مندوب روسيا الذي اقترح تعديلا يدعو
الى تعليق الاعمال
القتاليه التعديل الروسي صوتت لصالحه
اغلبيه الدول الاعضاء في المجلس واعترضت
الولايات المتحده باستخدام حق نقض
الفيتو ان الابتزاز والضغط بمختلف اشكاله
كان اداتين استخدمته الولايات المتحده
لفرض انذار لهذا المجلس اما ان يعتمد نصا
يرضيها او انها ستعرقل اي قرار يصدر عن
المجلس ان القرار لن يكون فعالا ونحن
مقتنعون ب ذلك انه وبسبب ضغط الولايات
المتحده التي استحوذت على المفاوضات
والنقاشات في الكواليس بشان مشروع القرار
تم افراغ النص من احكام بالغه
الاهميه القرار الذي رحب به رغم ذلك
كثيرون يرفض التهجير القصري لسكان غزه
ويطالب بادخال الوقود والافراج عن
المحتجزين ويؤكد ان غزه جزء لا يتجزا من
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله والدوله
الفلسطينيه القرار اعتمد بعد اسبوعين من
العمل المتواصل والمفاوضات الشاقه
والمداولات الساخنه تخلل بعضها غضب
وانفعال وانتهت الى صيغه غير مرضيه
لكثيرين لكن كان يتعين تمريرها كخطوه اخرى
متواضعه من مجلس الامن